kamilla Mendez and Charles Melton spark
daily rumors and beyonce is being sued
for extreme witchcraft and it's the
music Friday this is the daily dandy
with some tea on those Riverdale stars
fans are convinced are more than just
co-stars IRL because why let Lily
Reinhart and Cole Sprouse have all the
fun off-screen huh that's right the
Internet is shipping Camilla Mendez and
Charles mentioned after an eyewitness
told me news they saw the two kissing at
the movies a source told them quote
Camilla sat next to Charles and leaned
on his shoulder as the lights were
dimming my friends saw them kiss now now
now it is possible Camilla had a secret
to tell him or maybe she was just sleepy
alright but also the evidence is
starting to stack up y'all like this
most recent photo of them sharing the
same towel on a yacht you're probably
thinking whatever then they're with
friends okay well then how about this
romantic fireside Instagram story that
they both share no signs of any of their
Riverdale co-stars there it makes sense
that chameleon Charles would find love
right one they're cute too camellia
reportedly split with her hometown love
Victor Houston and three co-stars dating
in real life is not a new thing it
happened with : Lily it's happened with
Blake Lively and Penn Badgley it's
happened with Ryan Gosling and Rachel
McAdams still Camilla has said in the
past she doesn't like dating actors in
fact she told nylon magazine actors are
emotionally complicated but who can
resist this face
alright I ship it how about you guys do
you stand a real-life riverdale couple
crazier things have happened
case in point you guys see this one of
the on says ex drummers has accused be
of extreme witchcraft and casting spells
on her and killing her cat according to
very bizarre Court docs obtained by the
blast
Kimberly Thompson says she worked for
Beyonce for seven years and claims be
caused the loss of many jobs theft of
homes the murder of my pet kitten magic
spells on my lovers and numerous broken
relationships you can't make this stuff
up she also alleges beyonce has been
tapping her phones and controlling her
finances now a judge denied Thompson's
request for a temporary restraining
order but the best part of this story is
the number of folks on Twitter there are
actually
seriously I think part of the reason is
Beyonce and jay-z have fed Illuminati
conspiracy theories for years and she
even addressed it information is funny
with all I have to say is if Beyonce is
a witch then I'm joining the coven
alright it's time to get into some of
this new music Friday beginning with
Dinah Jane of fifth harmony the girl
drop it bottled up today and has
recruited ty dolla sign and Markie bassy
for her first solo song
[Music]
[Music]
now this is a reunion of sorts for Dinah
and ty dolla sign who was featured on
five H's work from home i but guess who
else is back Avril Lavigne she released
her first record in five years called
head above water
[Music]
Alvar was diagnosed in 2014 with Lyme
disease her battle kept her out of the
spotlight for a number of years he was
actually with her at her first red
carpet appearance since her hiatus back
in people I'm feeling a lot better it's
been a long time and for me to be able
to be here and I'm making a record right
now I've just you know I I have my life
back
which is amazing it's something and I
continue to work out every day and just
like grateful to be making music and
I've written a really powerful record
and a really emotional album sort of
reflecting on like where I'm at today
and finally Rita Ora brought the fire
for this new joint
here's let you love me
[Music]
alright guys that's all the tracks I
have for you we'll be back Monday with a
brand new daily Denny so go to enjoy
your weekend bye bye